[ TICKING, BEEPING ]
ALL RIGHT,
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA TO DO IS
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THESE TWO
COUNTERWEIGHTS WITH THIS WIRE
AND WE'RE GOING TO LAY THEM
ACROSS THIS PIECE OF ICE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
WILL HAPPEN TO THE ICE?
-I THINK THE ICE IS GONNA BREAK.
-IT SEEMS REASONABLE.
YOU WANT TO TRY IT?
-YEAH, I'LL GIVE IT A SHOT.
ALL RIGHT, COOL.
OKAY.
GET IT CENTERED THERE
AND --
AND WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY
GONNA LET IT GO.
BUT RIGHT THERE IS GOOD.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING RIGHT NOW?
I THINK THE WIRE'S
GONNA PROBABLY SPLIT THEM
INTO TWO SEPARATE CUBES.
SO YOU THINK
THE WIRE'S MOVING THROUGH
AND THE ICE IS ACTUALLY KIND
OF FALLING APART?
EXACTLY, YEAH.
-WELL, THE WIRE IS SINKING...
-MM-HMM.
...INTO THE ICE,
AND ICE ISN'T CRACKING.
-YEAH, YEAH.
-WHICH IS SHOCKING.
Woman:
IT'S IN THE MIDDLE THERE,
BUT IT KIND OF SEEMS
SOLID ON TOP.
SO, I GUESS,
AS IT'S SPLITTING,
THE ICE IS JUST
FORMING BACK TOGETHER AGAIN?
YEAH, IT'S A REALLY INTERESTING
PHENOMENON
THAT SCIENTISTS
ACTUALLY DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND.
IT'S CALLED REGELATION.
Narrator: REGELATION IS WHAT'S
AT WORK WHEN YOU ICE SKATE.
THE FRICTION OF THE SKATE
CAUSES THE ICE TO MELT A LITTLE,
ENHANCING ITS SLIPPERINESS.
BUT THEN IT RE-FREEZES
AS IF NOTHING EVER HAPPENED.
-CHECK IT OUT.
-NO.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
-IT'S ALL ONE PIECE.
THAT'S CRAZY.
IT STILL GOT THE LINE
FROM THE WIRE. THAT'S SO COOL.
OH, MY GOODNESS!
LOOK AT THIS!
ISN'T THAT CRAZY?
OH!
THIS IS FABULOUS!
IT'S ALL ONE PIECE.
Narrator: SO...
YOU DON'T -- YOU'RE ACTUALLY
SLIPPING ON A MICROSCOPIC LAYER
OF WATER CREATED BY THE PRESSURE
YOU PUT ON THE ICE.
AND IT WILL RE-FREEZE AS SOON
AS YOU SLIP AWAY.